happy April Fool's Day now since this is
a nice show I can assure you that
everything on today's show is a hundred
percent true but you have no reason to
believe me so revel in the mystery I
guess it seems as if the witcher 3 is
all set to give you a hell of a lot of
bang for your buck and i'm not talking
about the game sexy card collecting
minigame replying to a tweet inquiring
about the games length senior designer
damian moneyer said hard to say if you
do everything I say 200 plus hours
previously developers said a project red
said that it might take around a hundred
hours to complete the game but that
statement came from back in March 2013
it's safe to say you may want to set
aside a big chunk of time come May
nineteen when the game releases on to
xbox one ps4 and PC blood-borne may be
the talk of the town but it's also been
saddled with a fairly significant bug
capable of breaking the game that bug is
now rectified thanks to the game's
latest patch which updates the game to
version 1.02 the fatal bug would occur
if you'd cracked into an online
multiplayer mode by using either of the
resonant Bell items in the Forbidden
Forest after which you could not obtain
the Lunarian key which is pretty
important if you've set your sights on
continuing to progress the patch also
fixes a bunch of other bugs including
the controversial item duplication
exploit if you thought all that money
you've been dropping on pre-orders and
new release games was excessive then you
may want to shift your attention to the
guy who's now spent over twenty two
grand on star citizen
thirty-nine-year-old IT guy wolf night
not only has an extraordinarily cool
name is also a big fan of star citizen
so far investing twenty 2501 dollars
into the yet-to-be-released game night
described himself as having a pokemon
complex saying i have to have them all
preparing to the game ships and he does
night has a limited edition two thousand
five hundred dollar javelin destroyer
and bought the ten-thousand-dollar Wing
Commander
which comes with 44 ships and what is
certainly my favorite part of this whole
story you're probably wondering why
death cloud imperium games haven't given
the sky more attention well in fact they
have cloud Imperium often hims a chance
to play the game with creator chris
roberts multiple times but Knight has
said quote he has better things to do
for those of you worried about Knights
financial well-being it sounds like he's
pretty well off and simply treats this
as his hobby that he likes to spend
money on let me know down in the
comments which game you will drop 22
grand on if you had to pick one you can
head to gamespot we've got stories on
the resolution for batman arkham knight
on ps4 and the closure of playstation
home those it from me today we have
Easter holidays here in Australia and
the UK so Chris waters will be taking
care of all your news requirements for
the rest of the week have an awesome day
believe nothing and I'll catch again on
Monday